on monday clark county school district
students will head back to class today
the district held a back to school
kickoff event
kate houston spoke to superintendent dr
jesus jarre to see how he will approach
some key issues
clark county school district
superintendent dr jesus jarrah
highlighting ways to move forward from
the pandemic
while many are preparing for in-person
learning the effects of social isolation
and distancing
have not gone away we don't know how
deep
the scars are last year 24 students died
by suicide
mental health support systems such as
beacon alert and wellness checks will
continue
dr jarrah is also encouraging more
community partners to come together
to support kids there's 310 thousand
kids i don't have 42 thousand employees
we need the community to wrap their arms
on our kids as the district
assesses the loss of learning during the
pandemic they're also encouraging
students and staff to stay home if sick
adding this is not the time for perfect
attendance
we will support our students you know
through distance education make sure we
catch
them up on their work while students
want to get back to normal
dr dara says they will need to follow
strict guidelines
such as covid 19 testing for some sports
teams
we're going to be testing our high risk
sports
you know soccer football and
and volleyball we're going to be doing a
weekly covet test the start of the
school year is coinciding with an uptick
in covid 19 cases
dr jarrah is urging everyone to listen
to health officials get vaccinated
wear your mask follow instructions so we
are in school in our classroom with our
kids
kate houston 8 news now